well vote 2023 the local elections let's
give you a sense of just how the
complexion of the local authorities
around England have changed and you can
see there's a lot less in the way of
blue than there was previously and one
just way of underlining that is to look
at the share of counselors from each
different major party and what you
probably make out look this period here
where labor were behind the
conservatives that has now been reversed
labor now the biggest party of local
government as a result of these local
elections well that turns into a general
election Victory or not that is a big
question but certainly what's not under
question is how bad a nice it has been
for the conservative party this is just
showing you a dial showing you the level
of performance and they've gone down
down down down down by more than a
thousand seats more than a thousand
councilors losing for the conservative
party how about for the labor party well
similar things similar exercise except
this time of course they are up in net
terms up into what might be considered
good territory there so a good night for
security stoma a good election for
kasekistama but the lib dam is actually
going even beyond that although in
numerological terms it's not quite as
much they've gone well beyond
expectations in terms of the wins the
net winds from the liberal Democrat
Party also the green party's doing
brilliantly by compared with
expectations as well add it all up and
this is the House of Commons projection
from Michael Thrasher our elections
analyst showing that if this was kind of
extrapolated onto the next general
election you're talking about
298 uh seats for the labor party that
would make them the biggest party in
Parliament but still short of the 326
that seats they would need to win an
overall majority